der bolt ja wie ein ach ja das ist ja
auch tatsächlich ein löwe und unfassbar
dazu ihr haustier
in kuwait im süden von kuwait city filmt
ein anwohner diese irren szenen auf der
straße
eine junge frau fängt ihre entlaufene
raubkatze wieder ein das video
verbreitet sich rasend schnell weltweit
im internet kein wunder solche bilder
sind schon eher ungewöhnlich
lokale medien berichten dass kurz darauf
auch die polizei dazu gekommen sei und
der frau geholfen habe in jungen löwen
wieder zurück in ihre wohnung zu tragen
in der seiten von exotischen haustieren
inklusive löwen ist eine populäre mode
in vielen golfstaaten heißt es obwohl es
meistens nicht erlaubt ist in kuwait
ebenfalls nicht ob die frau eine strafe
zu erwarten hat ist unbekannt
[Musik]